you became the first american journalist
to be exiled from russia
well that that took place in 2013 um
and
basically
i had gone to ukraine before of course
there was no war at that time
uh i went to kiev to renew my visa this
is a standard bureaucratic procedure i
had all the necessary documents
and uh
the rule is the same for everybody you
have to leave the country get it renewed
and then come back in i had an apartment
in moscow i was accredited in moscow i
was planning to live there and stay
there
uh i was informed by a diplomat uh in
the russian embassy uh in kiev that my
presence on the territory of the russian
federation was undesirable that this had
been the conclusion of the so-called
competent organs that's a euphemism
for
the fsb the federal security
service which is the successory
organization
to the kgb
and i was banned from entering the
country so i couldn't go back i mean all
my things were there in the end my son
uh went to moscow and packed up my
things and brought them back out
and that was it
uh the moscow times which is an english
language
paper in moscow
uh
wrote wrote an article about it they
said it wasn't surprising that i was
expelled it was surprising that it took
so long really yeah
and um
in fact i have a long long record of
confrontation
with
the russian authorities and then the
soviet authorities before them because i
i went to to russia for the first time
in as a correspondent in 1976
uh as the at that point the very very
young correspondent of the london
financial times
and in
1979 there was an attempt to expel me
which failed it was uh
it was based on the idea or based on the
assumption
that
neither the british embassy nor the
american embassy since i was an american
working for a british publication and in
those years that was very unusual
uh would defend
me but in fact they both did and they
threatened to expel russian journalists
from both london and washington and
those russian journalists
were in fact intelligence agents and
they didn't want to lose them so uh they
allowed me to stay in in moscow and and
i was able to
remain there for three more years to
work on a book which eventually uh
you know was published
and consider i had intended it to be
about
the soviet totalitarian system
but because history kind of began to
move very fast it was ultimately about
the
the fall of the soviet
uh totalitarian system
and uh after that i couldn't go back
for uh a number of years my i was
blocked when i tried to to travel to the
soviet union
but in the la
in the last years of the soviet union
after the gorbachev reforms had gone
very very far i was finally allowed back
in i was the last american journalist to
be allowed back in and it turns out i
was the first to be expelled
aft in in post-soviet
russia
but between the time that i was allowed
in and the time that i was expelled
uh
there were
uh
20 23 years that i was going back and
forth and writing about russia i wrote
wrote other books
what made it what made you interested
in going over to russia in the first
place and
was there
any suspicion from russia that you could
have been in u.s intelligence
there's always that suspicion uh they
but but they have extremely
uh thorough
ways of keeping track
of western journalists
for one thing we lived in the soviet
times in buildings that were bugged
and where there were video cameras and
where there were guards outside the
buildings and where everyone who came
and went was registered and observed
uh
you know we didn't have mobile phones in
those days but the phones
uh were all tapped the only way to have
a private conversation was to go to a
booth and put a two kopec coin
in into a a tin telephone and try to
dial a number in fact it was
uh
it was
quite an effort actually to get the damn
telephone even to work let alone to get
through to somebody but if you called
from your home then everything was of
course monitored
uh so they knew pretty well what
correspondents were doing who we were
with whom we were meeting
intelligence agents are
really although there's a lot of
mythology about this uh their their
principal job is to recruit sources
and uh
that means for example finding people
who worked in the russian or soviet
government who could
provide
secret information everything i did was
open in public and i didn't i didn't
make any such efforts to establish such
contacts
the other oh and the the other thing was
that all of the drivers secretaries
maids and service personnel
in the foreigners buildings all worked
for the uh kgb at that time so it's hard
to conceal very much from them
and
uh
and in fact uh
i had no interest in doing that i i
thought that
i wanted to make it clear that i was
operating openly and and according to
the law
and that i had a legitimate right as a
representative of the western press
and the democratic world in effect
to gather truthful information to make
it known
what sparked your interest to originally
go over there
and how old were you when you first went
over there well when i first went over
there i was a graduate student okay i
was a graduate so it was actually in
1969 i'll tell you how old i was so you
at that time was 21. wow yeah and i went
there because i was a graduate student
at oxford university in in england
and
i had always been interested in russia
and then when i i
i went to study at oxford
suddenly russia was
close i mean you could get on a train
uh in in london and of course you had to
get off the train to get on a ferry and
then and then uh take the ferry to the
hook of holland and pick up another
train but nonetheless you could
buy a ticket in london
uh
and take a train that would uh
eventually lead you to uh to moscow and
i didn't want to miss that opportunity i
went there many times not many times but
a number of times spend as much time
in the soviet union as i could and just
became fascinated with the place
and of and with the language
i
yeah russian language
because i at uh i went to a high school
in chicago
on the south side of chicago and it was
in the neighborhood of the university of
chicago
and it was a crazy coincidence but there
was a woman there who taught russian
and the high school students had the
option of
we we had a choice it was french spanish
german latin
or russian
and i uh
i asked my father at that time i was i
was 13 i i asked him uh
what what language do you think i should
take he said yeah i think you should
take russian it might be might be useful
someday i couldn't imagine
how it could be useful because i knew
even at that age that very few people
were able to go to the soviet union that
to live there you had to be part of
a special diplomatic community
it never
crossed my mind at that time that i
might one day be part of that community
but that's what happened
and uh
i also did something which i would
actually advise any student to do
which is i didn't quit
once uh many many of the people who took
russian gave up on it
it's a difficult language
many of them decided oh heck i'm not
gonna try struggle with this i'll i'll
study spanish you know in the case of
people who had
a language requirement that they had to
fulfill
but i uh after four years of high school
russian during which i didn't learn very
much
i thought that well look
i still have a little bit of a
background and why not build on it so i
i
i took russian when i went to the
university of chicago because to
graduate from uh the university of
chicago in those days you had to have at
least one year of a foreign language
and then when i got to to oxford i
continued
and fi and then
needless to say i got practice when i
when i traveled there and i spent one
summer
at a taking a special russian course
that was organized by the
british soviet friendship society and i
signed up for it so little by the point
is little by little i improved my
knowledge of russian and so that when i
went to moscow
i had a base
and of course i worked hard with a tutor
and finally finally got to the point
that every journalist should get to
where i could go out
and talk to people in their own language
and
uh
and kind of circulate as as almost as if
i were
a soviet citizen
you